is it was there pressure on you in these
modern times to come up with a more
diverse cast i remember the original
jackets was a bunch of white boys um i
see there were two new members who are
black and there's a woman
in the jackass crew did someone say hey
man we're behind the times here you've
got to include it's got to be more
inclusive we need we need to include
more jackasses we knew we wanted new
new talent
because
it would probably look weird if it's
just all the old guys
right so we wanted to bring on new cast
members and we just reached out uh to
the people we knew the jasper dolphin
was on loiter squad
jeff and jeff did that i helped produce
and eric monaka i had me i'd made a
movie with and
in the case of rachel we're like you
know let's bring a girl on bring a
couple of girls in and uh i didn't know
rachel but i was a fan of hers on
instagram rachel wolfson
and and we brought her in and talked to
her she's hilarious she's super smart
her her her mom's i believe a a judge
her dad's a dis district attorney in
vegas her sister's an attorney she's a
very good family
like her mom she's like the same
person who sent oj to jail is the same
person who sent me to my room growing up
she goes but we both got out
that's right
she's funny and who comes up with the
idea that you're going to give rachel um
all the women want big lips now so we're
going to take a scorpion and in order to
give her those big full lips we're going
to have the scorpion bite her lips who
comes up with that is that you nah
i think maybe jeff tremaine
came up with that jeff comes up with a
lot of great ideas so
and rachel is tough
like we would have her do things and you
know she licked the stun gun
and really
didn't it didn't really faze her right
if it was one of the guys who did that
they would have been screaming and
falling over but rachel's tough as nails
johnny by the way he he didn't tell us
this but i read it in gq this is going
to be his final jackass movie
that's what i was wondering
that yes
you know i'm stepping back from large
stunts there who knows if there'll be
another jackass there could be another
jackass with the younger crew and then
just pepper in the old guys here and
there it's possible i'm not saying it's
the last
jackass but i am saying that i can't
take any more hits to the head i've i've
done enough and for myself and my family
i'm i've officially retired from that
you paid your dues
when you walked toward that cannon you
know it was like
do that ugh
i love that cannon stunt thank god they
did the slow-mo because i was like did
he extend his arms and show the wings
and you do
that's all i was concerned with rob is
like no matter what happens i want to
extend the wings i wanted to get that
and i did that and i'm like whatever
whatever else happens is gravy